This steak isn't actually steak.
It's made of beetroot; seaweed;
pea protein, and algae.
And it's fresh off the printer...
Just outside Barcelona in the Catalonian Farmland,you'll find the meatiest of restaurants.
El Santuari is renowned for its extensive
range of exotic meats.
Wagyu
Crocodile
Zebra
Kangaroo
And now 3D printedvegan steaks, cutlets, and fillets.
I am Giuseppe Scionti.
I am aCEO and founder at Nova Meat, and I am a bioengineer by background.
Josep and I we only have a name in common because he's called Josep in Catalan and I'm Giuseppe in Italian.
But the rest, we come from different worlds.
He's a meat lover, I'm trying to solve the meat issue, and find an alternative to that.
As a child I was interested both inthe nature world, dreaming about the Amazon rainforest,
and also my grandfather was aninventor and it was some kind of a model to me
so I was watching cassettes about Da Vinciand other inventors and scientists of the past.
Giuseppe is the brains behind Nova Meat
and they're not making your average vegan burgers.
His background in tissue engineeringhelped him develop a 3D printer thatrecreates the taste, texture and aromaof real meat.
It even reacts like meaton the grill.
Microfilaments are ordered ina very specific way so that it recreatesthe structure and the function of an animalmuscle.
We move that big machine and weare able to do it at that scale of hundredsof kilograms per hour afterwards.
[Music]
I remember when we tried the steak the firsttime I was very worried that he was working with tough cuts
and we were working with justa prototype
but he was very excited.
[Music]
But then he gave us very interesting inputs sothat we could improve these products very much.
In my opinion, it is the most straightforward wayto save the planet
and this is mymission from now until I die.
This unlikely pair might not share all the samevalues...
but they are always happy to share a meal.
[Music]